is it possible to make music out of a
brick just an ordinary brick inspired by
this friendly person that commented on
my last seeing sounds I bet you can't
make music out of a brick you too so of
course I was like challenge accepted
we have a bunch of these leftover bricks
lots of room for trial and error for the
track I'm just gonna go onto Spotify and
select the number one global top 50
[Music]
blinding lights by the weekend just did
it okay totally we are limited that what
we do know is there'll be loads of
percussion sounds and hits flow kind of
ambience in the comment the word tool
was mentioned which I guess gives us the
creative license to make use of some
tools but still the bricks the bricks
will be the main musical instrument he's
gonna add some tweets this is going to
take a lot of imagination but we have
keys I'm pretty sure we can create a
shaker I've got a normal shaker yes just
gonna open it up crush up some brick put
it in there
[Music]
yeah a shaker made of brick in a
previous singsong she saw me make bass
strings with my fiance's hair ties I'm
just gonna do that again with bricks
it's still a brick but now it's a brick
guitar I'm thinking we're gonna try and
make brick feet the moment of truth oh
we got a brick flute then I had this
idea to create an epic intro out of
brick dominoes but soon realized that
the base of the brick is too large to
keep the momentum so I got my tools and
mix some cement stacked up all the
bricks and pave them together let them
set overnight and then spray painted
them in a way that they would fall to
reveal the weekend the weekend we stack
them up I took a deep breath let's do
this and let's just say failed failed
miserably
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] okay let's call it there oh that
was just ridiculous oh my gosh oh I
guess so anything keeping me saying
throughout this lockdown period is to
try and challenge myself creatively yeah
please suggest objects you would like me
to create the tripod of or a track you
would like me to recreate in the
comments below and please subscribe to
my channel for more it's just a simple
click of a button and it goes a really
long way as well as don't forget to turn
your notifications ball on and other
than that don't forget your awesome
route and I'll see you next week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]